if you're willing to get your hands
dirty it's possible to build your
ultimate dream ride from stylish and
powerful
to eco-friendly let these diy masters
take the will
and watch them make their dream rides
come true
[Music]
by
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
bicycles it's a special everything a
special frame
especially wheels a special paint
everything is special
the bicycles we make is make we love
because it's with our hands
[Music]
you know those bikes snoop and countless
other rappers rode around in
you know the ones that ooze that west
coast style
low rider bikes low to the ground
chromed out gold plated
they're an extension of low rider car
culture and they all started here
i am the godfather of the lord bicycles
when i was 10 years old i used to fix
all the bikes with the neighbors
i always dreamed with a motorcycle and a
car but since
i was too small and no money so i put my
mind in bicycles a mainstay in compton
and west coast culture
these iconic bikes were actually first
created in mexico
[Music]
i brought the lord rider to california
in early 80s and soon after
locals took notice of the shiny swaggy
rides hanging in his shop
when i started making bikes and put it
in a display people come
and say hey can you make me one of those
and then they spread and now we have
customers from all over the world
[Music]
this is one of many creations right here
he
almost practically put everything on
here
he blew my mind when he when he put it
on there for me
[Music]
it's a completely different than the
regular bike and the way they look and
the way they
drive is art
people dream and we make the dream come
true
[Music]
the wheel a perfect function
invented in the stone age to this day
the wheel provides the same function as
it did those thousands of years ago
but one man is flipping everything we
knew about the wheel
on its end my name is michael bertoff
i'm not an engineer
but i did what most engineers wish they
could
when i was a little kid i like to take
things apart and see what they're made
out of
i tried to make something new out of
them and i still like doing it to this
day
in 2012 i was running an hr company and
i turned on the movie tron
i was drinking a coffee and i thought
that was a very cool motorcycles
in the movie they're called light cycles
and they have these hollow wheels
and i remember thinking well i'm not an
engineer but couldn't we do something
useful with that empty space
i imagine you could put things in the
wheel that lived outside of it with an
electric wheel
for example the motor and the battery
[Music]
a wheel that powers itself is a much
more universal wheel than a wheel that
needs something else to power it
make it super compact super efficient
and that's really what inspired me
pretty much everyone said it was
impossible they said that if it could be
done
it would have been done already by a
real engineer
so i ignored them and i quit my job and
then i met dakota decker
who ended up leaving spacex to build the
wheel together with me
dakota and i spent about two years
before we came
to the version that we put up for retail
it's a much more
compact design takes up the same space
as a regular wheel
but it's got everything in it the entire
powertrain
the battery the motor the computer this
wheel is extremely environmentally
friendly
it's electric power and it's a very
efficient use
we have made thousands of bicycles into
affordable electric vehicles all over
the world
we see that we can contribute to the
future of transportation with the
georgia wheel
we see vehicles that nobody has ever
made before
being able to be made now imagine a car
imagine the possibilities when you take
all the guts out of a car
because you just don't need them anymore
the opportunities really are
endless
in mexico city cars are everywhere over
3.5 million to be exact
and it's not exactly great for the
environment but fear not
because there's a solution that can
change all of that and that solution
is a volkswagen beetle
welcome to alto redemiento automotris a
mechanical workshop that specializes in
transforming old gas gas-fueled cars
into electric cars
[Music]
alvaro de la paz is the engineer behind
the car conversion
and then there's hector my name is
hector ruiz and i'm a computer scientist
hector is responsible for gathering the
electrical parts and making sure they
work
right yeah i do the purchasing
the extensive testing of the components
if we have to burn
something i'm the guy in order to
learn how to do an electric car
conversion
you don't need any specific degree it's
something very simple after
reading a lot of books and taking
training courses i believe
anyone can do it hector and alvaro
learned that converting older cars is
both cost effective
and safer for the environment
[Music]
by removing all the parts related to
fuel combustion they can install the
electrical components
to have a fully functional electric car
with zero emissions
[Music]
this car makes me free it's like the
nirvana of the cars
you are free from gas stations we are
free from the checkup every six months
reusability is something that the
general public has to
take into account in order to be
pollution free
if we want to have a better world for
our children
or grandchildren or future generations
we have to be part of this solution
so i believe the best way to start
something important for the world
at large is to do this kind of projects
[Music]